[inaudible]
one of the commonalities, one of the patterns that you spot really quickly.
If you interview hundreds of world class performers,
and I just interviewed 130 or so for my new book tribe of mentors is the fact
that they have consistent morning routines.
They have some type of recipe of boot up sequence that they use to win the day
in some fashion and it ranges from, for instance,
mindfulness and that could be mindfulness meditation where you find,
say Evan Williams, who is well known for blogger Twitter,
also medium a who spends time every morning as I do with some type of meditative
practice, could be insight. A could be a transcendental meditation.
You could use an app like headspace,
which I think is a great place to start and it trains you.
It allows you to practice becoming more aware and less reactive so that you're
not thrown off by the unexpected challenges and problems of the day and that
helps you to be much more productive and much more centered.
You can achieve that in other ways. Gratitude is a common element.
So Tim O'Reilly, who's just an incredible entrepreneur, thinker, writer,
and a thought leader in silicon valley goes for a run and we'll take a
photograph of a single flower on his run every morning. Right?
And this teaches you to pause, to pause and to assess how you're say,
responding to things.
So that is a really beautiful practice that can be done with gratitude lists.
I use something called the five minute journal about Whitney Cummings,
incredible standup comedian writer,
and much more also has gratitude lists. Uh,
and this is saying naming three things that you're grateful for each morning.
Tony Robbins does this. Brian Grazer,
incredibly well known iconic TV and film producer also does this.
I think he's had 180, I mean nominations or something like that.
And that achieves very much the same thing of present state awareness and
looking for the positive as opposed to fixating on the negative.
And last but not least, you have, say Jocko Willink,
retired navy seal commander who will lay out his clothing,
his workout clothing the night before so that there's no conscious decision
required were willpower or lack thereof could intercede.
His clothing is ready. He's already set his to do list for the next day,
wakes up at,
he wakes up at four 30 that's not quite when I wake up and grabs the clothes,
boom directly to the gym and he has a home gym where he does his workouts.
This is also very common where people recognize these very busy,
very driven people that if it's inconvenient to work out,
they probably won't do it.
So Jocko has a gym where barbell plates squat rack,
three sets of rings at different heights like kettle bell and you're good to go.
That's all you need.
So this is a few of the things that I've seen repeatedly in different forums
with hundreds of top performers that they use to win the morning so they can win
the day. Hey guys,
if you're enjoying the tips and tactics and how to on this channel or in the
podcast, the Tim Ferriss show, I made this for you.
Try to mentors short advice from the best in the world.
This is the book that I wanted to read. So I went out and I put it together,
created a dream list of 130 of the best at what they do.
People who are icons, legends, and ask them all the same questions.
These are people in some cases I want it to reach out to.
My whole life ranges from many, many billionaires,
cofounders of every company imaginable,
elite athletes ranging from surfing to tennis to power lifting. Everything else,
country stars, actors, directors, and you can spot the pattern.
So some of my friends have said this is the easiest to read,
most useful book that I've put together yet.
So checking out tribal mentors.com you can find sample chapters,
the whole list of mentors, everything, tribe, mentors.com.